the Terran have had their day in the Sun
the Zerg have had their time to shine
and now it's all about the Protoss in
starcraft 2 legacy of the void joining
me onstage due to have forgotten your
name entirely I'm a total boner fine
Jason Hawk Jason Huck lead designer from
blizzard dude thank you for coming here
let's talk about legacy of the void and
you guys are like really spinning it up
got the gotta like the trailer released
recently for sort of a little prologue
talk about that actually because ahead
of the full release you guys are
bringing out some new missions yes yes
those three missions free for everyone
sort of ties the story from heart of the
swarm into legacy of the void so um yeah
so it's going to get sort of people a
head start on what's on the events of
like that void of the worst one of the
things about the starcraft two like
expansions has been those sort of
faction specific stories and sort of how
they connect and how they focus in so
people are going to be getting their
their quality Protoss time oh yeah oh
yeah this is all zeratul story of
zeratul what he's been up to since wings
of liberty and heart of the swarm so ya
gonna get to see him in action and
there's gonna be a bunch of new units
coming along as well for the Protoss
let's talk about some of those yeah so
um well the titular in beta right now
are the disruptor in the Adept so the
disruptor is a robotics unit it's a
little robot that when you activate it
it it opens up into like a damaged field
and you drive that to wherever you want
it to explode and when it explodes just
massive damage killing whatever units
are into the area of effect it's just
something that the your opponents are
gonna have to like really keep a keen
eye out for is it had a small profile on
screen as well no it's pretty obvious
because it's it's the only thing in the
Protoss army that looks like that so if
you see that you know what's common yeah
and then of course you want to dodge it
because there's you have a time a time
frame of moving units out of the area of
effect before it explodes and it just
does it murders everything that's under
that area so that's more of like a maybe
a flanking kind of creature or like want
to distract them somehow yeah it's a
kind of a trickery unit if you can get
them to
gage and you can keep your disruptors
back then you could use your disrupters
to sort of counter anything that might
be like engaged with your zealots or
something so I think there is a lot of
cool like trick tricky moves with it in
my life yeah I like it trickery yeah and
the Adept the adepts is a fairly
straightforward unit she's like Captain
America she's got a shield she throws
the shield sort of attacks with it um
and she comes from the cheese a gateway
unit she has an ability called a phase
shift that lets her face she can you use
this ability and then she moves you
moved this shadow version of her to
another spot on the map and after some
time she'll teleport to that spot so
like we've seen it used in ways like you
move up a ramp with it so you send up
the shadows up the ramp and then you
know 10 seconds later boom she's in your
base so there's a lot of like you can
use them to escape as well so oh you're
like I'm engaged with something I don't
want to really fight with so I used my
shadows I'm if they survive that amount
of time then they'll teleport to
wherever their shadows are so can you
cancel the teleport or is it once you've
activated a set time from now you're
gonna automatically do the teller
currently you can't but I mean we play
with all this stuff in beta so maybe you
oughta teleport or maybe a little
cancelled maybe not because that would
be mean just have like little shadows
just taunting people we are never
materializing in their face yeah talk
about trickery yeah oh yeah so those are
two of the three new units coming to
legacy of the void well those are the
two units for a Protoss okay but in the
campaign we also have a ton of new units
that our campaign specific like we
always do for all our campaigns sure
we've got like bringing back the river
and all like a lot of the fan favorite
stuff so and so that campaign is going
to catapult off of the prologue yeah the
prologue is coming out like pretty soon
or like analyze we're gonna announce
some more in July about when it comes
out okay it's it's roughly though some
time before legacy of the void so we
because we have an announced over
release date yet we're not really sure
so all right now legacy the void also is
you know in addition to the new campaign
bunch of new units guys are also
experimenting with some different stuff
in the competitive scene
oh yeah you mean like with our Khan mode
and stuff Shah Rukh Khan mode is that
definitely one of those sort of ones
you've been talking about a bun tree
yeah I mean we got our Khan mode we got
automated tournaments coming we've got
sort of it's not really competitive but
we have another mode ratting called
Allied commanders which is that's more
of a cooperative experience play Archon
modes in beta now and it's been really
well received by the fans like it's a
really good way to teach people how to
play starcraft 2 like if you're not a
very experienced player and you have a
friend that's like really good at the
game they can mentor you so you play
together you share control this base and
it's just a really good entry point into
the multiplayer for starcraft 2 so
that's always a big question for
starcraft right is the entry point
because you know starcraft 2 has been so
big for so long on the competitive scene
yeah that when a lot of people here if
they think i'm just going to get eaten
alive if i go anywhere near that game so
our con mode is one move you guys are
sort of bringing to address that sort of
entry-level stuff you know Britt
welcoming people into the game are you
doing anything on the eSports side to
sort of assert starcraft tues dominance
again or like really like enliven it on
the eSports scene oh there's there's
plenty of things that we're like working
on currently that I can't really talk
about but I mean you'll see as it as it
starts to happen as we get towards the
WCS font finals in various regions and
everything so it's always like a ongoing
front for us so yeah absolutely yeah and
you guys also of course have other
competitive stuff going on in your
Studios you got heroes of the storm oh
yeah I definitely sort of a diversion
from what starcraft 2 it is all about
but has there been any learning sort of
across the the way from the different
teams working on these competitive
endeavors uh oh sorry well I'm just a
little distract you mean they're singing
duck tales are there some singing oh
yeah yeah its e3 obviously you talking
about duck tales so I just you know
heroes of the storm is now something
blizzard is pushing big time yeah like
with starcraft 2 you guys sort of feel
like those are going to capture
different audiences or you're hoping
people are gonna play both or i think
we'll see
everything they're like here's the storm
was a great entry point for people who
want to just get into strategy games in
general because one unit you can control
this one unit micro that's like oh great
I had now understand sort of a strategy
game in general especially a real-time
strategy game and that might be a spring
point for people like getting into
starcraft 2 as well they're like oh you
know i wanna this this game of mass
armies facing off against each other
that sounds that might be really cool so
i would like to try that so i think it
kind of it feeds off each other in a way
lice and it's kind of invigorating the
strategy genre so which is pretty
exciting for strategy fans yes well yeah
yeah it's good one strategy fan more
meat for the grinder yeah on the
competitive scene yeah um one thing
about our convo that interests me you
know you sort of talk about how it's a
good entry level mode to sort of team up
with someone who's maybe more
knowledgeable can sort of teach you
about the flow of the game I it also
allows you to because you have two
players sharing the responsibilities
maybe do a little bit more micromanaging
it's certainly in terms of your unit
strategy you can have you know obviously
someone could be building someone could
be unit managing but you could also have
two people sort of doing totally likes
maneuvers and subtle like that so it's
not just about that entry level there's
also yeah pretty high competitive oh
yeah it could it like and we're gonna
we're seeing like some tournaments
farming up now with pros are con mode so
those are going to be amazing to watch
because you're going to have these guys
that are my crowing all sorts of units
in ways that they probably even couldn't
do it on their own like I've seen some
stuff with just the fans that they were
doing with like roaches in in our con
mode and it's hilarious like some of the
stuff they're pulling off bro burrowing
all the right time to heal up or dodge
damage and stuff so yeah it's it's
really cool it's like a new it's a new
game almost watching it with our con
mode no kidding third expansion in and
still trying to make it a new game kudos
sorry mr. muck ah let's talk about
legacy of the void when it's there's a
beta coming up and then do you have a
release date in mind give me some dates
well I I mean we're not prepared to play
can't give you that the typical response
that we give everyone knows when it's
ready and why
now we're still working hard on
releasing are getting it ready for
release or yeah but is there a beta on
the way as well Bay this happening right
now on it's on yeah multiplayer beta has
been happening for a couple months now
yeah knew it started back in March but
it's still going on Go Go and go to what
website to sign up I just go to the
starcraft 2 website BAM so battlenet any
of those sites you can find your way
there so mr. hook thank you very much oh
thank you it's been a pleasure great
great to all right ladies and gents
we're gonna be back on gamespot's III
stage here just a moment stay with us